verheerender anschlag in mogadischu ein
sprengstofflager reißt mindestens 90
menschen in den tod
streik chaos vor silvester in paris
gehen wieder tausende gegen die
rentenreform auf die straße der
dauerstreit liegt den öffentlichen nah
und fernverkehr lahm und silvester ohne
böller seit heute darf wieder feuerwerk
verkauft werden doch immer mehr städte
suchen alternativen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag den sport in etwa 15
minuten präsentiert norbert lehmann
wunder haben doch schon seit jahren
leidet somalia unter unruhe und
unsicherheit jetzt wurde das muslimische
land von einem besonders schweren
bombenanschlag erschüttert mindestens 90
toten und 50 verletzten darunter viele
studierende und schüler der sprengstoff
war offenbar in einem laster versteckt
und explodierte in einem belebten
stadtviertel in der hauptstadt
mogadischu zu der tat hat sich noch
niemand bekannt
sandra times berichtet rauch steigt auf
über somalias hauptstadt mogadischu
die explosion ereignete sich am morgen
mitten im berufsverkehr
bisherigen erkenntnissen zufolge
sprengte sich ein selbstmordattentäter
mit einem fahrzeug in die luft
ein lastwagen ist an einem belebten
kontrollpunkt in die luft gesprengt
worden es gab viele tote und verletzte
es ist noch nicht klar wie viele
menschen getötet wurden aber es sind
viele vor einem krankenhaus betrachten
menschen die leichname suche nach
angehörigen
bei den meisten opfern handelt es sich
laut behörden um studenten auch zwei
minibusse mit schulkindern soll der
anschlag getroffen haben in somalia
kämpft die regierung mit verschiedenen
gruppierungen und milizen um die
vorherrschaft in vielen gebieten hat die
regierung die kontrolle längst verloren
auch mogadischu gilt als instabil
die explosion heute war so gewaltig dass
auch umliegende gebäude teilweise schwer
beschädigt wurden die explosion war so
stark dass sie mich umgeworfen hat so
was habe ich noch nie erlebt
es wird vermutet dass die islamistische
al shabaab hinter dem anschlag steckt
die terrorgruppe beherrscht gebiete im
süden und im zentrum somalias und verübt
immer wieder anschläge
doch bislang hat sich niemand zu der tat
bekannt
dramatische meldungen kommen aus der
syrischen provinz idlib nach un-angaben
sind allein in den letzten zwei wochen
235.000 menschen von dort geflohen
der türkische präsident erdogan warnt
vor einer neuen migrationswelle richtung
europa die provinz idlib im nordwesten
syriens gilt als letzte große
rebellenhochburg im land hier sollten
eigentlich seit monaten die waffen ruhen
aber die vereinbarung ist längst
gebrochen die syrischen
regierungstruppen fliegen mit russischer
unterstützung massive luftangriffe und
zwingen die menschen zur flucht
vollgepackt sind viele auf dem weg
richtung türkei halim hosny die syrische
armee unterstützt von der russischen
luftwaffe soll bei ihrer
militäroffensive im nordwesten des
landes bereits dutzende orte erobert
haben ihr ziel bleibt die letzte
rebellenhochburg die opfer zivilisten
zehntausende sind auf der flucht die
meisten zur türkischen grenze
doch die ist geschlossen die lager davor
schon hoffnungslos überfüllt heilig
werden neu errichtet bei temperaturen
nahe null und dauerregen bieten die
zelte nur wenig schutz
das wasser läuft durch zählt die kinder
sind krank wir konnten die ganze nacht
nicht schlafen
eine humanitäre katastrophe klagen
hilfsorganisationen vor ort
internationale hilfe fehlanzeige dabei
findet der bürgerkrieg vor den augen der
weltöffentlichkeit stadt klagt yusuf der
21 jährige syrer lebt als flüchtling in
istanbul
auch er hat verwandte in idlib sie
schauen ständig in den himmel nach
flugzeugen abgeworfen werden
die situation ist schlimm täglich
sterben dort unschuldige menschen
sterben kinder amerika wo ist
deutschland es geht nicht dass nur die
türkei hilft klagt mohammed auch in
syrien dort unterstützt die regierung in
ankara
gegner mohamed und yusuf haben in der
türkei bis auf weiteres schutz gefunden
wie rund 3,7 millionen syrer auch anders
die menschen in der provinz idlib dort
läuft die offensive der syrischen armee
unvermindert weiter nach deutschland da
gibt es möglicherweise bewegungen im
tarifstreit zwischen lufthansa und der
gewerkschaft ufo
gestern hat der ufo angekündigt ab
montag bei der tochter germanwings zu
streiken heute hat der konzern der
gewerkschaft ein konkretes angebot
gemacht das sieht schlichtungsgespräche
für alle offenen tarifthemen vor teilte
das unternehmen mit
außerdem sei die sofortige übernahme des
teilzeit tarifvertrags der lufthansa
möglich
aber dieses angebot beeindruckt die
kabinen gewerkschaft ufo offenbar wenig
isabel de la vega ja so ist es also
dieses angebot klingt erst mal gut sagte
ufo dass die kabinenmitarbeiter der
germanwings künftig zu den gleichen
bedingungen wie die premium airline
lufthansa als teilzeitkräfte beschäftigt
werden können
die ufo sagt es sei ein
erpressungsversuch man wolle also so die
gewerkschaft in eine friedenspflicht
zwingen
und außerdem seines wohlfeile reden für
die öffentlichkeit insofern sieht man
auch wieder wie unversöhnlich sie die
sich die parteien gegenüberstehen der
streik ist nicht vom tisch das angebot
wird abgeschmettert und die reisenden
müssen sich ab montag für drei tage auf
einen streik der kabinen mitarbeiter
einstellen ihre es gilt ein
sonderflugplan aber sie müssen sich
weiterhin bei der airline erkundigen ob
ihre flüge gehen oder nicht
dankeschön für diese informationen vom
frankfurter flughafen isabel de la vega
war dass umweltministerin schulze hat
sich in die debatte um ein
flächendeckendes tempolimit auf
autobahnen eingeschaltet sie hält ein
tempolimit von 130 auf autobahnen im
gegensatz zu verkehrsminister scheuer
für sinnvoll es verringere tödliche
unfälle
und spare jährlich ein bis zwei
millionen tonnen kohlendioxid die
gewerkschaft der polizei regt an dass
die bundesregierung ein unabhängiges
gutachten in auftrag geben soll um die
aktuell emotionsgeladene debatte auf
eine sachliche ebene zu bringen
nach russland dort ist jetzt avantgarde
einsatzbereit ein neues waffensystem das
in der lage sein soll die raketenabwehr
der usa auszuheben
die hyperschall rakete fliege 20 mal
schneller als der schall erklärte
präsident putin sein land reagiere damit
auf pläne der usa die russische nukleare
abschreckung zu untergraben
wegen ihrer hohen geschwindigkeit sei
die rakete nicht abzufangen
aus moskau berichtet christian sind sie
soll die neue vorkämpferin des
russischen militärs seien die in
russland entwickelte rakete ab und gart
hier bei einem test im letzten jahr nun
ist die neue hyperschall rakete laut
russischen verteidigungsministerium
offiziell im einsatz
ich gratuliere uns allen zu diesem
wegweisenden ereignis für die ganze
nation und für das militär avantgarde
ist ein neuer sprengkopf auf einer alten
interkontinentalrakete nach russischen
angaben hat die neue rakete eine
reichweite von 4000 kilometern und liegt
mit der 20 waren schallgeschwindigkeit
sie soll während des fluges das ziel und
die flughöhe ändern können und durch
spreche jeden derzeit bestehenden
raketenschild das strategische
gleichgewicht zwischen den usa und
russland verändert sich dadurch nicht
wirklich aber es könnte der anfang eines
sehr gefährlichen wettrüstens sein mit
anderen waffensystemen als absolute
waffe hat präsident putin die rakete
bezeichnet das neue system sei praktisch
unbesiegbar
denn wir siegreich sein wollen muss
unsere ausrüstung besser sein als die
der anderen ländern
das ist kein schachspiel bei denen wir
mit einem unentschieden zufrieden sein
können
russland will mit dem neuen
raketensystem stärke demonstrieren und
trotzdem weiter an einem neuen
abrüstungsabkommen arbeiten
ist es in moskau doch bis das
verabschiedet sein sagt putin will
russland auch weiter neue waffensysteme
entwickeln eine streikpause wegen der
weihnachtsferien oder silvester dieses
ansinnen von frankreichs präsident makro
haben die gewerkschaften abgelehnt und
so wird der öffentliche nah und
fernverkehr in frankreich weiter
bestreikt vor allem in paris seit
nunmehr 24 tagen
zudem gab es heute wieder
demonstrationen alles um die von magna
geplante rentenreform zu verhindern
aus paris in ihrem schein als lehrer hat
roma roubini gerade ferien
zuvor hatte er vier tage lang gestreikt
stadt zu unterrichten
in meiner familie bin ich der einzige
beamte die anderen können ja nicht
wirklich streiten deshalb mache ich das
lehrer zugführer angestellte sie alle
wollen die geplante rentenreform
verhindern
während der feiertage war die zahl der
streikenden leicht zurückgegangen umso
wichtiger war es den gewerkschaften
heute sich zu zeigen
unterstützung bekam sie von denen die
vor einem jahr mit den demos gegen makro
angefangen haben
hier laufen sie jetzt zusammen
die gegenwart groß rentenreform sind und
die gelb westen und beide erhoffen sie
sich davon neue schwul für jeweils ihre
bewegung
einige hundert vertreter der gelb westen
schlossen sich an
unter ihnen auch natalie wir kämpfen
hier für alle mit den eisenbahnern die
auch hier sind und die nicht aufgeben
werden
und ich sage allen anderen protestiert
mit sie ist früh aufgestanden um
pünktlich hier zu sein denn der streik
beeinträchtigt den verkehr in frankreich
weiterhin metrolinien sind geschlossen
der bahnverkehr bleibt eingeschränkt
damit wollen die streikenden auf ihren
protest aufmerksam machen
die demonstration am nachmittag wurde
mehrfach gestoppt feuer aus der menge
beantwortete die polizei mit tränengas
einer der anführer der gelb westen wurde
leicht verletzt
romero biene gefällt dass sich
streikende und gelb westen zusammengetan
haben
läuferin hatte vor einem jahr schon mit
ihnen protestieren sollen dann hätten
wir micron schon gestürzt
es ist tag 24 der proteste in frankreich
bei einem lawinenunglück in südtirol
sind mindestens zwei menschen ums leben
gekommen eine frau und ein kind laut
medienberichten soll es sich um deutsche
handeln
drei weitere menschen wurden verletzt
als sich am mittag die lawine löste im
skigebiet schnalstal westlich von meran
ob es noch weitere opfer gibt ist
bislang nicht bekannt
neue wendung im fall des am
nikolausabend in augsburg erschlagenen
feuerwehrmanns vor weihnachten waren
sechs junge verdächtige freigekommen
nun müssen sie wieder in haft das
oberlandesgericht münchen hat die
haftbefehle wegen beihilfe zum totschlag
wieder in kraft gesetzt unter anderem
wegen fluchtgefahr
die sechs jungen männer hatten auf dem
augsburger königsplatz einen streit mit
dem 49 jährigen ein siebter aus der
gruppe soll das opfer mit einem einzigen
schlag getötet haben
in drei tagen ist silvester und das
heißt auch seit heute gibt es wieder
raketen böller und feuerwerk zu kaufen
für die einen ein muss für die anderen
um verantwortlich und zwar nicht nur
wegen der müllberge am tag danach und
der belastung für tiere sondern vor
allem auch wegen des feinstaubs davon
pusten feuerwerke laut umweltbundesamt
jedes jahr 4200 tonnen in die luft das
sind etwa 15 prozent dessen was pro jahr
im straßenverkehr freigesetzt wird
manche städte bieten jetzt alternativen
wie claudia kugelmann zeigt einkaufen
für die nacht des jahres in der es viele
immer noch so richtig krachen lassen
die fans des lauten jahreswechsels
wissen genau wonach sie suchen lautet
man am besten mit defekten verschiedenen
effekten
doch münchen rüstet ab in der
silvesternacht gibt es an den böller und
raketen bahn zwischen stachus und
marienplatz diese bilder sind wohl
geschichte der grund raketen schossen
quer böller wurden in die menge geworfen
zu viele menschen zu viel alkohol das
feuerwerksverbot gibt es wegen
gravierende vorkommnisse die zu gefahren
für leib und leben fürchten lärm müll
brand und verletzungsgefahr
es gibt viele gründe die gegner ein
feuerwerk sprechen dazu kommt die
umweltbelastung die deutsche umwelthilfe
hat den 98 städten und gemeinden anträge
auf böller verbote gestellt würden auch
davon aus dass viele städte eben verbote
umsetzen werden einige hamas auch schon
getan
und wenn dann eben auch die zeitung
dieses verbotsregelung erleichtert wird
für die kommunen und städte dann werden
sich da bin ich mir ganz sicher in den
nächsten jahren viele dazu entschließen
landshut ist beim ballermann vorreiter
feuerwerk ist in der historischen
altstadt bereits seit dem vergangenen
jahr verboten dennoch sind 10.000
landshuter zum feiern vor das rathaus
gekommen wenn man etwas verbieten wenn
wir etwas einschränken was durchaus
viele bürger gerne machen dann sollte
man was alternative bieten
landshut hat sich für einen laser show
entschieden doch das feuerwerk hat auch
hier noch fürsprecher
ich will diese shows von den raketen
haben muss ist schön anzusehen klar aber
das was es mit sich bringt für die
umwelt dafür lohnt es sich nicht bei
allen bis zum letzten böller das
feuerwerk an silvester brauch ist in
einigen städten bereits angezählt in
leipzig tummeln sich zurzeit
it-spezialisten hacker und technikfreaks
auf dem viertägigen chaos communication
congress das ist eine veranstaltung des
chaos computer clubs der auch den
nachwuchs im blick hat für alle zehn-
bis 18-jährigen gibt es den so genannten
jungen hacker tag michael b warum er hat
sich das mal umgeschaut an die 17.000
besucher strömen in die leipziger
messehallen wenn der chaos computer club
zum kongress lädt darunter sind nicht
nur alte nerds sondern erstaunlich viele
kinder und jugendliche chaos macht
schule heißt dieses angebot des klubs
denn früh lautet wer ein echter hacker
werden will
wer hier mitmacht ist aber kein anfänger
mehr sondern will tiefer in die digitale
welt eintauchen
am meisten außenstehenden da stehen halt
nicht wie funktioniert das ganze
nein heutzutage kannst du überhaupt
nichts mehr machen ohne irgendwas
digitale selbstlob haben wir stellen so
manche nachbarn sondern über so viel
neugierde freuen sich auch die eltern
unsere generation hat es nicht gelernt
also unsere generation da kam plötzlich
das smartphone
wir hatten es in der hand und wir sind
wird sich erinnern und sagen ja gut wir
bestimmen jetzt wie hast du damit
umzugehen
ich glaube dass die nach die generation
die jetzt nachgekommen dass sie viel
klüger damit umgehen die veranstalter
wollen die welt der daten noch
tiefgründiger erschließen
das was wir eigentlich erreichen wollen
das heißt für uns digitale mündigkeit es
geht dabei nicht nur um technische
aspekte sondern einfach um das
interdisziplinäre ist es kann zum
beispiel darum gehen wie es vielleicht
das geschäftsmodell von einem sozialen
netzwerk wie gern man laden vielleicht
das internet verschickt er darauf alles
zugriff was kann man mit diesen daten
machen
der erste schritt dazu ist heute schon
mal getan
auch bei noah funktioniert am ende alles
so wie es soll
wie jedes jahr schwärmen rund um den
jahreswechsel die sternsinger aus heute
war die eröffnungsfeier für die
bundesweite spendenaktion in osnabrück
und 2000 mädchen und jungen zogen
verkleidet als die heiligen drei könige
caspar melchior und balthasar durch die
innenstadt unter dem motto frieden im
libanon und weltweit werden rund 300.000
sternsinger spenden für kinder in not
sammeln und jetzt sind wir beim sport
norbert morgen startet die
vierschanzentournee in oberstdorf heute
war qualifikation unter haben die
deutschen springer den fans so richtig
hoffnung gemacht stephan leyhe dritter
markus eisenbichler fünfter und karl
geiger sechster alle drei zeigten sich
in starker verfassung
der weiteste satz vor über 15.000
zuschauern an der schattenbergschanze
gelang dem österreicher stefan kraft
stephan leyhe lächelt zufrieden und zu
recht denn nur zwei springer sind heute
besser also ja bei wechselnden
windbedingungen zeigt der 26-jährige
weiter ansteigende form
als toni dritter im vergangenen jahr
kennt er die spielregeln auf dem weg zum
erfolg schließlich nur zu gut
das ist immer noch mühsam es ist harte
arbeit aber jeder sprung gibt mir immer
mehr selbstvertrauen und so langsam geht
doch die diese dampflok wieder los den
besten sprung vor 15.500 zuschauern an
der schattenbergschanze zeigt der
österreicher stefan kraft der sicher zu
den mit favoriten auf den gesamtsieg
zählt vergeblich auf dieser kleine junge
dass richard freitag aus aue zu seiner 1
zu starten form zurückfinden möge als 59
steidl freitag sang und klanglos aus
positives fazit aus deutscher sicht
unter den für morgen qualifizierten
zwölf besten springern sind neun der
zwölf gestarteten deutschen zum
skilanglauf da haben die norwegerin
therese johaug und cgi yougov aus
russland den auftakt der tour de ski in
lenzerheide gewonnen
beste deutsche in den massenstart rennen
wurde viktoria kahl zwölfte und jonas
dobler als dreizehnter ja von ski
nordisch ski alpin erneuter triumph für
dominik paris bei den herren
er gewann auch die zweite
weltcup-abfahrt in bormio und bei den
frauen da dominierte michaela schiffe in
den riesenslalom von lienz ihr 63
weltcup-sieg damit ist sie jetzt hinter
lindsey vonn auf platz zwei der ewigen
bestenliste deren läuferinnen innehalten
nach dem souveränen sieg vor einer woche
noch auf einem für sie untypischen 17
platz beim riesenslalom in courchevel
meldet sich schäferin heute
eindrucksvoll zurück mehr als eine
sekunde vorsprung hat die 24-jährige
us-amerikanerin auf die zweitplatzierte
maria sie nur aus italien katharina
liensberger aus österreich wird dritte
viktoria rebensburg enttäuscht mit zwei
fehlerbehafteten läufen und landet in
ihrem letzten rennen des jahres
auf rang 14 doch einfach immer vergessen
muss ja und dann weiter machen auch bei
den deutschen skirennfahrern keinen
grund zur freude thomas dresden
verzichtet wegen knieproblemen
kurzfristig auf einen start bei der
abfahrt in bormio team kollege josef
erste mit 21 dominik paris gewinnt auch
heute mit seinem sieg vor den beiden
schweizern us grünbühl und wertvolles
übernimmt der italiener die führung im
alpinen gesamtweltcup abschied auf
schalke von einer der erfolgreichsten
und beliebtesten deutschen
wintersportlerinnen biathletin laura
dahlmeier ein halbes jahr nach ihrem
überraschenden rücktritt als aktive
lässt sie sich noch mal von ihren fans
so richtig feiern in gelsenkirchen vor
45.000 zuschauern ja ein stimmungsvoller
ausklang tolle sportlerin bleibt ja uns
erhalten im zdf als biathlon experte
super ist das auch morgen gibt es
ruhiges hochdruckwetter sagt gunther
tiersch und führt das gleich noch ein
bisschen aus das heute journal um
viertel vor elf mit christian sievers
haben sie noch ein schönes wochenende
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
und darum liebe zuschauer für die
meisten von ihnen wird es morgen kühl
und sonne ich wir haben ja hohem
luftdruck und da passiert nicht allzu
viele mitteleuropa trocken geht's weiter
ganz anders von irland bis nach norwegen
mildes wetter mit regen und östlich von
uns rutscht kaltluft mit schnee richtung
mittelmeer david saam heftig zum teil
mit gewittern
ja bei uns bleibt trocken in der nacht
nur ein paar nebelfelder werden sich
hier an der donau bilden sonst haben den
klaren himmel leichter frost an in
norddeutschland morgen früh sind es etwa
0 bis -5 grad dort im süden mäßiger
frost minus 5 bis minus neun grad und
tagsüber na ja da haben wir den
dauerfrost wahrscheinlich weiterhin
einer donau im nebel
ansonsten sind es zwei gerade in berlin
und etwa sieben grad in der gegend um
düsseldorf herum
ja das wetter bringt ein paar dichtere
wolken an die küsten vielleicht auch im
norddeutschen tiefland dazu weht dieser
kräftige südwestwind sonst spürt man den
wind kaum mehr so ein bisschen den
sonnenschein allerdings so an der donau
wahrscheinlich bleibt der nebel den
ganzen tag über hängen und es geht ruhig
weiter auch über den jahreswechsel mal
ist es sonniger mal auch ein bisschen
wolkiger und nachts gibt es immer frost
ihn einen schönen abend und machen sie's
gut